well maybe i'll start there with dominic
foxworth the espn writer commentator for
the undefeated former nfl quarterback
harvard business school grad
what a show off he joins us now dominic
uh which quarterback you think is going
to be hurt the most if there's no
preseason games uh i think i got to go
with borough i feel like that's the easy
choice but
for the other rookie quarterbacks
there's really no expectation that
they're going to start
borough is almost absolutely going to
start day one
and has no experience his first career
pass
outside of practice is going to be a
live nfl game and no matter what we say
about not having high expectations for
that team
there's always high expectations for a
rookie quarterback and i think you can
be ruined by that first season if it
doesn't go well
and those other guys have some
experience that i think they can fall
back on would you rather face cam newton
or jared stidham
oh that's a real question yeah i mean
right now going into this season given
that stidham has been there cam we don't
know is it even close
no i mean we don't know about cam's
physical health but i don't think it's
even close
what we've seen from stedham on the
field doesn't come close in the nfl
or even in college frankly what we see
from stella doesn't come close
to the ceiling that cam newton has so
stedham isn't a stiff
but he's certainly not the athlete that
cam newton is so even
without knowing the system all that well
i'd be more concerned defensive players
hate hates athletic quarterbacks mobile
quarterbacks dual threat guys like that
there is no defense for that they
compromise you in every way if you're in
man
you turn your back on them they get out
if you're in zone they buy time man
turns in the zone they throw deep passes
and then
when you're cam newton and you're built
like a defensive end tackling him does
not seem fortunately i got it
out of the league before that was a
possibility for me
but i wonder about this you know they
were trying to usher in a new wave of
quarterback here
right unlike lamar jackson is the
anomaly to me
like it's hard to find somebody who
rushes for 1200 yards and throws for
over 30 touchdowns here you know josh
allen runs
but i don't think he's capable of
putting up those kind of numbers here so
mahomes is capable of running but he's
known for his arm so
are we seeing a different type of
quarterback or is it just
this is lamar jackson and maybe a little
bit of kyler murray no i think we're
absolutely seeing a different type of
quarterback it's impossible to name a
team that has a young quarterback
that is not athletic and doesn't run
some plays and the best quarterback we
have is patrick mahomes
and even he runs quite a bit you think
of some of the biggest plays in the
playoffs last year that kind of lazy
spin he did into the end zone against
the titans
that was a running play and i think you
mentioned earlier in the super bowl he
put himself at risk and he fumbled down
in a red zone because he took a big hit
like everybody is going to run that's
the way that it's going to be maybe it
shortens their careers but
that dynamic is something that's so
important to put stress on the defense
because
obviously it makes it easier for your
running back to run the ball if people
have to account for you
it makes it easier in the passing game
if you can scramble and make things
happen if you
we give a lot of credit to uh andy reid
but if you go through those playoffs
which i happen to do a couple days watch
all the plays from the chiefs playoffs
again so many of the pivotal plays
were after patrick mahomes bought time
with his athleticism some of them he
actually ran
but so many of the big plays he bought
time with his athleticism
and released the ball deep downfield and
to back up uh
you know what you're talking about there
have been 48 quarterback seasons with at
least
500 rushing yards in nfl history exactly
half have happened since 2010.
yeah the game has changed but the
athletic quarterbacks have always been
there i think you're going as they get
older
they're going to have to develop
something else because their athleticism
will leave and also their bodies will
break down but you think back to i wrote
a piece with mina kymes
uh before the draft where i i said lamar
jackson was
the best we said he was the best
quarterback in the draft and
in the right situation he would be great
but in that process i went back and
looked at a bunch of
other quarterbacks and john elway was
so athletic and i re-watched the drive
against the browns that
important play every single play
was something about his athleticism was
something about him buying time all the
passing plays or him scrambling rolling
out
maybe taking it for a short run or and
also maybe connecting with someone down
the field
all the pivotal plays in that drive so
it's not something that's new but john
obviously
developed into a different type of a
pastor and i don't think that's going to
change i think
guys are running more now but if you're
going to have a long career you're going
to have to develop something else but
i'm completely fine honestly i heard you
in the first segment
saying maybe you have an eight or seven
year career
i'm fine you if you are here for a good
time not a long time
that is okay with me i would rather have
this version of lamar jackson than some
watered-down version of lamar jackson
for 15 years
we're talking to dominic foxworth he is
a writer
and uh commentator for the undefeated
which is espn's content initiative
exploring the intersections of the
sports race
and culture how necessary is it to have
at least one preseason game
in particular this season yeah i mean i
think
well it's certainly not necessary
because they aren't going to have it so
we'll figure out how
how players figure out things yeah
i mean i think that this season is going
to be a unique one and it's going to
benefit teams that have experience
and teams that are efficient so i think
in the past when you have a lot more
time
maybe there are times where you can make
the best of a longer offseason and
you'll have
uh maybe just 50 of your practices are
productive
now that if that happens to a team now
they have a lot less time so the teams
that are able to be
productive in that time and the teams
that bring in players and
sadly this goes to what the patriots
have always done they've always
prioritized experienced smart guys
over having kind of stars and
rookies around them that's been kind of
the patriots model of roster
management is they'll get some mid-level
guys that don't cost
a ton of money but would normally be out
of the league
because uh they're they aren't big
enough to warrant a big contract but
they aren't young enough to get the
small contract so teams
who have those type of players i think
will benefit in teams who figure out
ways
to practice efficiently and get the best
out of this time
will benefit and guys who have rookie
head coaches
they're in trouble like that's that's
that seems impossible
yeah i was wondering about uh stefanski
and cleveland that
you're walking into a situation that
feels
real it's tenuous here it just feels
like there's
there's tension there there's
expectations there
but man it could either be greater it
could go south quickly there
and you don't really get a you know an
off-season a pre-season to get ready for
just
going into your first head coaching job
yeah i can't imagine what that must be
like and that team
is a team that i think uh mentally and
emotionally
is on the brink like there are some
teams that could go through a losing
streak and just have
some installed confidence and maturity
that this team hasn't developed yet so
it's gonna be really hard for them
considering that they don't have a
normal offseason
seeing how things go if they have a
rough start in that division where they
have
at least two really tough defenses to go
up against in the ravens and the
steelers
yeah you start to wonder about this even
a simulated game
like you've been in simulated games
right um
it's not even a pre-season game like how
do you prepare
without having a game to really prepare
for well i mean i think you can go back
to college that's what we did in college
we would start
our season's first real game was a real
game there's no preseason games in
college
so you can try to do similar things to
that but you also don't want to hit too
much
in nfl practices because you don't want
to get your own players hurt
it's different in college because the
rosters are so deep and there's so many
players that
frankly you know plan on playing and the
coaches don't necessarily care so it's a
little bit easier to go
kind of full speed but i do think that
many of these players are comfortable
with
it it may not be pretty to all of us but
everyone no one's gonna be at a
disadvantage necessarily
so i think that's the thing that i'd be
more concerned about if anything like if
i were a player right now or even a
coach right now i'd be looking at this
as
an opportunity like everyone's going to
be at a disadvantage no one knows quite
how to prepare for this if i can figure
out
how to prepare for this this is my
chance of getting edge and maybe that's
just like
whatever mumbo jumbo i would tell myself
to get motivated but that's the way
i would think about this is like look
it's not like i'm at a disadvantage i'm
not the only person who's not getting
these opportunities
everyone's not getting them how can i
make the best of them and dominic was
the uh
president of the nfl players association
back in 2012 how confident would you be
going into this season what role would
you play if you were the president of
the nfl players association right now
telling everybody else yeah i mean i
think that the most important thing is
the safety and i think the players and
jc tretter is the
president at this moment i think they've
been clear about the positions that they
were taking is to prioritize the health
of their players and i think it was made
obvious by
them advocating for no preseason games
because if you think about it the stars
have a disproportionate amount of power
in this and
they tend not to play in preseason games
and that preseason revenue goes directly
into the cap
so those guys their financial incentive
would be to have preseason because
that's money in their pocket
or money in the cap that could go into
their pocket without
actually going out there to play but
they stood up in unison and said no
we're not gonna do that and i know that
it's not perfect for all of the
undrafted guys who hope to make teams
but i do think that we all would agree
that less contact less travel less of
any of that stuff it's probably
it increases the probability that we
have a season and finish the season
you were born in england weren't you
yeah military base so i mean i'm still i
could still run for president if i want
to wonder
oh you can okay good yeah i know that's
what you're concerned about were you
there long enough to pick up an english
accent sadly i was not that would have
been cool if i could do that but
yeah i grew up in baltimore so i say two
and do
and those sorts of things not a cool
english accent uh
do you have a uh welcome to the nfl
moment when you were playing
ah yeah i mean i i do remember it came
in practice
so i grew up obviously watching a lot of
football and the dynasties
that i watched were the um cowboys and
the 49ers my brother's favorite player
was jerry rice so my rookie season
in um denver uh jerry rice was
in what his 21st season in training camp
and i my parents came out to watch the
training camp practice and
one of the early practices we were doing
one-on-ones and i
came out there and lined up and it was a
cornrow jerry rice across from me and
in that moment just for like a split
second before the snap it was like
damn that's jerry right and then i gave
him the business because he was because
he was old
and and then uh i made the team and he
decided to retire from that point do you
think that's when he decided to retire
if he could
if he couldn't beat you then it was time
to retire he probably looked over and
like i don't even know this kid's name
and
i can't get off the jam it's probably
time for me to shut it down
i'm getting covered by a guy who was
born in england here that's true yeah
the third round pick
from maryland i'm not sure uh jerry ever
took the time to learn my name or
remember me
but i certainly remember that moment hey
it's great to talk to you continue the
great work there at uh
the mothership and the undefeated and uh
we appreciate your time
i appreciate you dan thank you that's uh
dominic foxworth he's a writer and
commentator for the undefeated that's
espn's content
initiative exploring the intersections
of sports race and culture